we found this video this is from about a
year and a half ago this is the prime
minister of the netherlands basically
talking about how the countries that are
in power how they have to basically fund
the media so that nobody can figure out
what they're doing you need to free
press
at these moments to be able to explain
to the people what is really happening
but that costs money so one of the
police i have is big business here in
davos don't put all your money in the
internet advertising make sure that our
newspapers our news outlets also our tv
stations also in the future will be able
to pay sensible and and real
salaries to our journalists to be able
to do this i believe it is crucial
sarah
you work at the blaze
i work with the blaze you work at a
place that is independent no one's
telling you what to do what to say
etcetera etcetera it is not government
funded by the way the video we just
showed you that was from rebel news
which of course is ezra's outfit up
there in canada for as long as ezra
remains in canada but
this idea that governments should be
funding news
completely insane huh
yeah i mean i think uh china would agree
uh north korea would agree um russia
would probably agree i remember the good
old days when uh media and lawmakers at
least here in america pretended to care
about a free press whenever you know
president trump would utter one mean
word about them and they'd be screaming
about freedom of the press or he would
ban
one reporter from one media outlet while
allowing other reporters from that same
media outlet to enter the briefing room
and they were screaming about how
freedom of the press was under attack
now we're just talking about having
state-run media and uh just like the
communist party of china and everyone's
like oh yeah that seems like a great
idea there's no conflict of interest
there it's all about protecting the
narrative it just is like the social
media companies that we're talking about
twitter facebook mark zuckerberg uh
perag
they have to protect the narrative at
all costs they know that which is why
they need the journal the journalists to
do their dirty work for them is it's
just sick
ezra can you talk a bit about what's
going on in canada right now relative to
this bill that's being pushed that i
think has actually been signed already
where pretty much everybody is going to
you're going to have to now register and
they'll be able to control what you can
and can't say and of course you already
have the cbc which is basically in bed
with trudeau and the liberals so you
already have a state-run media in canada
yeah you know you'd think
inflation price of gas groceries
whatever would be the most important
thing to a government today but trudeau
actually it's censorship and control the
internet he has four different bills
going through parliament some have
already passed um they're going to
regulate the internet like they regulate
like
tv stations and radio in canada which is
very strictly
um trudeau has been paying the media
hundreds of millions of dollars but only
the media that quote he trusts that's
the word he used trustworthy media
which means his media he's colonized
them
he's introduced a journalistic license
called the qcjo qualified canadian
journalism organization and it's his
staff that will determine whether or not
you're qualified and if you're not
qualified and obviously we were refused
that status you will be
his next bill is to require
facebook google
to boost
the qcjo the qualified licensed media in
the rankings and d boost so it's not
just that google and facebook have their
own algorithms that are biased trudeau's
bill would require them to introduce his
biases into the algorithm to silence his
critics like us
and to promote the ones that he trusts
it's a licensing provision one last
thing dave it's not just the government
money and in canada
99.9 of journalists now take government
money 1500 media companies i didn't even
know there were that many in canada are
on the dole there's maybe 10 that aren't
including us
but google and facebook are now spending
hundreds of millions of dollars directly
subsidizing legacy media also in
australia in canada that's another thing
you have to be a qcjo licensed
trudeau journalist to get that big tech
money but if you're an independent
journalist but suddenly a third of your
money is coming from google and facebook
and a third of your money is coming from
the government
you're not an independent journalist
anymore at least not on anything
touching the government or big tech
journalists no longer work for their
viewers they work for oligarchs we
should start using that word oligarch
here why should we only call ukrainians
and russians oligarchs you don't think
bezos is an oligarch you don't think
zuckerberg is an oligarch someone who
has money and power and wants to rule
the world and to hell with the little
people and democracy we have our
oligarchs too
nick uh to that point i mean having just
done your movie capital punishment you
know we go through this absolutely sham
ridiculous i don't even want to call it
a trial i don't know what you can call
it other than a clown show this january
6 hearing which it's basically done
already and nothing came out of it there
was this pretend moment that they
claimed trump tried to grab the wheel of
the car i mean it's all so stupid
everyone thought it was a joke except
mainstream media they really loved it
doesn't that kind of prove the point
that ezra is making here
absolutely i mean i loved that idea that
trump fought his way through the back of
a limousine through the
good movie man to get to the driver yeah
it made him look even better than i
thought he was i didn't know he was like
some kind of superhero
but yeah i mean i'm old enough to
remember it being taught in school about
pravda and about soviet propaganda and
how
you know state-run media is a bad thing
they taught me that in history class in
high school and now i think what's
happening is that these journalism
schools they churn out these kind of
brainwashed people i mean khrushchev
said it back in the 50s we're going to
march through your institutions and we
will take you over without firing a shot
and that's what they've done to these
journalists and so many of them it's not
like some grand conspiracy they've all
been educated to accept this idea that
it's okay to take money from the
government and then
say what the government wants them to
say
and i it's it's gone so far that it's
really it's gonna take a long march back
through the institutions in order to
change things and to get these
journalists back to to the point of
actually reporting the actual news
rather than just being mouthpieces for
whatever government they serve
you